the cia
was conducting a variety of experiments
so was the military
um there are there's a lot of
speculation this project is so unknown
to so many of the uh
records were destroyed that you can go
off in a lot of directions
um who killed john lennon you know why
what
whoa sir hans story was he mind control
kid kaczynski is another one uh in my
books
i only deal with facts my
favorite chapter in all my books is the
footnotes everything is footnoted
everything comes from somewhere
so i wouldn't i don't deal with cases
like those i love reading about them
so i hope some i'm glad that other
people do write about those but in my
books uh i try to stick to the facts
and it's frustrating in writing about mk
ultra because
i'm uh painfully aware that i've only
uncovered a
small fraction of what mk ultra was and
what sydney godley did
so there's no concrete evidence
connecting to
ted kazinski or even charles manson or
any of that stuff
i haven't seen any evidence connecting
mk ultra
to uh to manson or to the unabomber
unfortunately there's so much that's
been lost
when sydney godley left the cia
he violated federal law by destroying
all the records
of mk ultra he had the support of the
director of central intelligence his
boss
in doing this as a result of that
there's huge gaps in what we know and
it's frustrating because i realize that
in telling the story uh
i've only scratched the surface and told
a small part of
what mk ultra was and what sydney godly
did
there was another guy of like a famous
gangster hitman who was in prison who
was one of his victims as well this is
actually an interesting story because
that's one
uh exception to the rule that we don't
know anything about what happened
whitey bulger the famous boston gangster
was an mk ultra victim and
we don't need the records of mk ultra to
find this out because he has written
about it
so as a young thug in his 20s
whitey vulture was sent to the federal
prison in atlanta georgia
there was a doctor there named pfeiffer
who was an
mk ultra subcontractor and pfeiffer was
sending back reports to the cia to
sydney gottlieb
about how prisoners responded to lsd
one of the prisoners that he recruited
was whitey bulger
he told those prisoners we're
researching
a medication for a possible cure for
schizophrenia
we need your help it's a humanitarian
project they were not told anything
about
the real motivation for the project so
whitey bulger had terrible reactions he
writes in his diaries about
having panic attacks that never left him
for the rest of his life and how he was
so psychologically destroyed by this and
given the amount of lsd that he was fed
over a period of
well over a year it's quite
understandable that he would have had
serious psychic reactions um
the footnote to this is that in the
1970s so
20 years later whitey bulger is now a
gangster
on a high level up in boston and he
he reads that there was such a thing as
mk ultra that's when the news
first came out and then he finds out
from a paper in atlanta that yes that
nice dr
pfeiffer who was i was helping trying to
find a cure for schizophrenia was
actually working for the cia
and this was all part of a project that
had nothing to do with schizophrenia and
they were just using me
he got so angry he told his fellow
gangsters
i'm going to go to atlanta i'm going to
find that pfeiffer and i'm gonna kill
him he never did that as far as we know
although pfeiffer did die an early death
uh apparently not violent but uh
it shows you that uh that's one just one
example
whitey bulger of somebody who had
tremendous
psychic disturbances maybe lifelong
from being a victim of mk ultra and you
can only extrapolate from that one
case how many others
he went on to murder tons of people
after after that right
he did and uh some lawyers
uh in the boston area were puzzled that
this didn't come up in his trial
maybe the defense lawyer should have
gotten up and said that uh the reason he
did it was that
mk ultra gave him too much lsd and drove
him crazy now
whether a jury would have bought that or
not i don't know but uh
the fact that gottlieb the cia and mk
ultra overlap with this boston
gangster project just shows you the
extremes to which uh
mk ultra went and now i find it hard to
believe that there's nothing like this
going on today
there's no sort of crazy secret
experiments that are going on today like
this
it would be naive to believe that
uh such a secret project as was carried
out in the 1950s would never be carried
out today
um very few people would ever have
believed that mk ultra existed
if you had shown them what was happening
while it was happening nobody would have
believed
uh doesn't that make it logical that
there could be things going on right now
that if you would find out about them
are so extreme that nobody would believe
them
when godly finally finished his mk ultra
work after almost a decade
he concluded that mind control is a myth
that you cannot actually make somebody
commit a murderer
if that person is fundamentally opposed
to committing murder you you cannot do
it that's just
made up that's movies uh
he made that conclusion after wreaking
horrific havoc and leaving a terrible
bloody trail behind him
but i think he was probably right and
that was the
overwhelming evidence not only of
everything that he had
researched over ten years but everything
that qualified psychologists had been
telling him but he just wouldn't listen
to
however if he was right that there's no
such thing as mind control maybe we can
say that he was right
given what was known at the time that he
was saying this
that was more than 50 years ago
the advances in computer science
cyber technology artificial intelligence
have been so dramatic since then we've
gotten into
regions that scientists like sydney
godley of the 1950s could not even
imagine
therefore although i i suspect that
godly was right when he concluded that
there's no such thing as mind control
it's not possible in the early 1960s
is it still true today i'm not so sure
and it would surprise me to learn that
no secret service is
trying to answer this question right now
as we speak
so how did mk ultra ultimately
ultimately dissolve and
what what did he do after mk ultra
obviously he destroyed the records right
mk
altered uh was not uh ended on a
particular day it faded away during the
early 1960s uh there were no new
projects the old projects
were allowed to fade away there were
successor projects
none of them were nearly as intense and
i think the horrors at
what was revealed about the cia in the
1970s
also led them to take quite a step back
from this kind of research but
that's not to say they never stepped
forward
again i i i really believe that uh
there must be things going on now that
are just as shocking
as what i've discovered about mk ultra
from back then
so mk ultra ended
as a project on its own but the idea
behind it
never really died and i think uh
in the modern age the question of
how you could try to control other
people's minds
in a battle situation or in a covert
action situation
must be intriguing some scientists who
are working for
secret services in the united states and
elsewhere well i mean
it's it's weird in the sense that it's
the same
it's the same thing as you know
making an excuse to do something immoral
making an excuse saying that oh this
other country is possibly doing this
and you know being fearful
of of being destroyed by them or them
coming up with this technology first
and then being able to crush us it's the
classic security dilemma
in international relations countries
take steps to defend themselves
those steps then seem aggressive to the
other country which then takes
aggressive moves
that then starts to spiral up again or
just make up make up
fake news exactly there's also a
psychological concept called uh
projection uh you imagine what you would
do
so you assume that the other guy is
doing that too right um
the thief always thinks everyone's
stealing from him
when cia prisoners were taken by the
communists in the 1950s we assumed that
the communists were horribly torturing
them and he wasn't using them as
subjects in grotesque
experiments they weren't but since we
were doing that
we assumed that what that's what they
must be doing and in fact that's why we
had to do it
because they were but actually it turned
out that they weren't
and we were